[Music]
the fate of the universe lies in your
shoulders now whatever you do don't push
this but cuz that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what I just said
conquer it no that's the button that
will kill everyone try again conquer
mm-hmm okay uh-huh conquer No
Showtime a-holes
[Music]
you say sir
you
does anybody have any paper out there I
want to put some tape over the death but
nobody has any tape not a single person
has pain you have an atomic bomb in your
bag if anybody's gonna have tape it's
you I have to do after you are wasting a
lot that's a really bad sign
if I touch someone I can feel their
feelings you feel yeah yeah I guess yeah
I feel a general unselfish love for just
murder no sexual no no I don't [ __ ] no
ha ha ha
see you stole everyone your deepest
darkest secret dude come on I think
you're overreacting alone you must be so
advanced
hahahahaha dick you ready
hey youtubers I am Groot we are Groot
new guardians footage let's break it
down and there is new round of the
spider-man giveaway going on so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
be sure to click the bell to turn alerts
on so you don't miss anything so giant
space tentacle monsters Marvel phase 3
is like full Rick and Morty maximum
tentacle it's like the Cronenberg
universe this is basically like an
interdimensional being the James Gunn
explained that the team is hired to take
down by a Yesha played by Elizabeth to
Vicki they had this really weird
relationship where she belongs to like
this genetically perfect race that super
uptight things go sideways then she ends
up coming after Peter quill in the
Guardians but like this is like one of
the big action set-pieces here when they
go after it like you can see Drax just
stabbing the crap out of it is just so
hilarious so if you couldn't tell from
all the baby Groot that they put in this
they're just trying to imply the tone
the humor and give you an idea for how
they up the scale so there's a whole lot
we don't see in here but like we're one
step closer to seeing ego because we see
mantas who has been living with ego her
whole life she's Peter Quill's
half-sister by ego the Living Planet so
I know that just sounds mind-boggling so
don't worry about that they'll totally
explain how he made himself a human body
and was able to procreate with a human
woman
but Gunn has just said that thematically
like the way he works in the film is
that he's this ancient being like we
learned in the last film like Peter
quill has ancient DNA in him and he's
been so lonely like he's been a living
planet how many other living planets do
you know about in the universe so being
so lonely that's why he made himself a
human body so that he could make himself
a family family is like one of the
biggest things about this movie finding
your biological family like Peter quill
searching for his father the Guardians
themselves as a family like the family
you make for yourself versus the family
you're born into so if you want to you
could consider ego the Living Planet the
big villain of the film but in terms of
actual villains that you would actually
go up against you have the Ravagers like
we saw in the first trailer they mutiny
against yondu so the guardians have to
help him escape that
forms the basis for why yondu is part of
the Guardians he was part of the
original Guardians team in the comics so
now he looks more like original yondu
and he's doing more original yondu
things but Michael Rooker is going to be
crazy in this so it'll be a lot of fun
they still haven't said anything about
Sylvester Stallone's mystery performance
but he wears a Ravagers uniform but I
think he goes beyond being a normal
ravager
but speaking of which they put baby
Groot in a tiny baby Ravagers uniform
you just see him go crazy through most
of the trailer so this is kind of like
the trailer that you would show off to
like the little kids - I feel like they
kept him a little baby just for the
younger audience just because you see so
many little kids going to comic book
conventions dress with like baby Groot
cosplay so keeping him a baby for most
of the film maybe not the entire film
but most of the film just allows them to
have a little bit more fun like don't
press this little red button that's
going to kill everybody but if you
haven't read the comics Groot is
effectively immortal as long as you have
like a little piece of his biomatter he
can completely regrow himself from even
the littlest of twigs but they said in
the movie he won't have most of original
groots
memories but he's effectively the same
Groot so you're getting a group with a
vastly different personality but
effectively it's the same character you
know that we are Groot type person so
they'll probably be a moment in this
like there wasn't the first film and I
do think we'll see him grow towards the
end of the film but for most of it he's
probably going to be dancing baby Groot
but it actually doesn't take him that
long to regrow himself in the comics
like he could actually do it in a
relatively short amount of time a lot of
you have also probably noticed that
Nathan Fillion has a cameo as Wonder Man
in the movie now they have a slightly
different spin on the character but it
is Wonder Man from the comics he had a
cameo in the first film but he was like
a full CG character so you really just
had to listen to his voice to know that
it was him but this time you actually
see his face on camera but the other big
thing they're selling this romance
between star-lord and Gamora no I don't
know
see you stole everyone your deepest
darkest secret dude come on I think
you're overreacting a little
you must be so advanced they kind of had
some chemistry in the comics but they
haven't really been doing that recently
they've had adventures with Captain
Marvel Iron Man joined them for a while
they're just kind of mixing and matching
them with other Marvel mainstream
characters but we won't actually see the
Guardians with the other Avengers till
infinity war in otherwise like it just
looks really good like it obviously took
him a long time to get these special
effects down the movies been done for a
while but they still have to do
post-production so let me know what you
guys think I just I love the way James
Gunn uses color he has a really good
sense of humor he has a really clear
idea for the story he wants to tell so
the narrative usually doesn't get too
muddied a like it doesn't fall into a
lot of the tropes of big superhero films
that you saw earlier this year with
films that probably got released before
they were ready to be but one of the
most fun things about James Gunn though
like I mean he's a great filmmaker but
he's also really vocal he has like a
really strong connection with the fandom
so he is like a lifelong comic book nerd
so I just feel like that helps him make
really good comic book movies because he
understands the characters and he
understands the way comic books work so
just a reminder that this is coming out
May 2017 they'll probably do like
another big Superbowl trailer there'll
be some spider-man homecoming before
then - Star Wars Episode eight will
probably be held for celebration they
might do Super Bowl trailer but now that
we're like approaching the end of the
year everybody just like blowing it up
for 2017 the amount of awesome stuff
that's happening next year is
unbelievable even the TV stuff - it's
just off the charts but let me know what
kind of guardians of the galaxy bonus
videos you guys want me to do while we
wait for more stuff to drop there's just
so many characters the stories are so
different from the earth-based Avengers
stories so there's all kinds of stuff
that we can talk about mister motika
we win this round of the spider-man
giveaway it's a $30 comixology gift card
I'm trying to like slowly hypnotize
everybody into reading more comics so
you guys can let me know if it's working
if you've started reading comics more
recently but there is a new round going
on right now I'll announce the winner
the next time I post a Marvel video
in related news there was a Last of Us
to trailer that just dropped so if you
guys want me to do a video for that just
let me know in the comments it's
actually a pretty rad game while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my Doctor Strange carnage
theory and you can click here for my
breakdown of the spider-man footage they
show it off a comic-con thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you